morning everybody it is uh seven o'clock
a warning this morning from the
ukrainian president that attacks could
move to nato territory following a
strike near the polish border russia
claims some progress in peace talks but
does putin really want peace as tens of
thousands of ukrainians continue to flee
the country news to this morning that
some children have arrived in the uk for
life-saving cancer treatment the health
secretary said javid joins us shortly
plus we'll get the view of the former
chief of the defence staff general lord
richard dannet it's uh monday the 14th
of march
a matter of time a warning from the
ukraine president that russian missiles
could hit nato territory following an
attack near the polish border
i repeat again
if you do not close our sky it is only a
matter of time before russian missiles
fall on your territory
nato territory
on the homes of citizens of nato
countries
and reports just reaching us of at least
one person dead three wounded after a
russian explosive hit a residential
building in the capital of kiev
new drone footage shows the aftermath of
an attack in mario paul as the red cross
pleased for a cease-fire in the besieged
city
poland struggles as refugees fleeing the
war keep coming while 21 ukrainian
children with cancer arrive in the uk
for life-saving treatment
two libyan jets suddenly attacked two
american f-14s
tributes to an oscar-winning star
hollywood remembers william hurt who has
died at the age of 71.
we'll bring you all the action from the
baftas which gets political the stars
show their support for helping ukrainian
refugees
everyone needs to do as much as they can
i think already today the news break
that there's been a record number of
people volunteering to take people into
their homes and i hope to be part of
that myself
also on the programme for you this
monday morning live after abramovic
going to be speaking to a board member
of the chelsea supporters trust as well
as the chelsea legend
pat nevin looking forward to that
[Music]
and we'll speak to the lead singer of
ukraine's most popular rock band using
his musical talent to raise morale among
soldiers
[Music]
morning everybody we start with a
warning from the ukrainian president
that russia will soon attack nato
countries after the weekend strike near
the polish border at least 35 people now
confirmed to have been killed in the
attack
the scene in kiev this morning where
reports are just reaching us of at least
one person dead three wounded after a
russian explosive hit a residential
building in the capital
let's take you through the other main
developments so far this morning
ukraine's president has reiterated his
call for nato to impose a no-fly zone
after a russian strike killed 35 people
on a military base 15 miles 12-minute
drive from the polish border
talks take place today between chinese
and u.s diplomats amid reports russia
has asked for military equipment from
beijing
a russian negotiator says there has been
substantial progress in talks with
ukraine and draft agreements could be
reached soon further negotiations
continue today
and 21 ukrainian children with cancer
have landed in the uk for treatment the
health secretary sadie javid will be
here in just a moment to discuss that
first our u.s correspondent greg milam
has this report
if the russians did expect to be
welcomed with open arms in ukraine's
cities the reality must have been
sobering demonstrators in the southern
city of kerson marching in protest at
their occupation go home they chant at
the military convoy
the response gunfire from russian
soldiers warning shots and people who
simply don't want them there it isn't
just civilians offering defiance in the
city of mariappol under siege for so
long since the invasion began the
ukrainian military released these drone
pictures of what they say is an attack
on russian armoured vehicles
and the resistance continues elsewhere
too as the elderly helped out of airpin
on the outskirts of kiev the mayor
estimates ten thousand people have
stayed behind
seventy percent of our city is now
ukrainian territory he says thirty
percent is controlled by russian
occupiers but we're doing everything to
liberate 100 of our city
it's to the west that a new front could
be of greatest concern the attack on a
training base on the doorstep of poland
and by extension nato
ukraine's president says the strike
should be a wake-up call to the west
i repeat again
if you do not close our sky it is only a
matter of time before russian missiles
fall on your territory
nato territory
joe biden returned to the white house
from a weekend at camp david and
concerns russia has turned to china for
military help his national security
adviser will meet china's top foreign
diplomat today to deliver a warning
uh they think that they can basically
bail russia out
they can give russia a workaround to the
sanctions that we've imposed
they should have another thing coming
because we will ensure that neither
china nor anyone else can compensate
russia for these losses
on the ground it was another night of
anxiety in the city of lev they
sheltered in a hotel basement there is
hope that more peace talks could bring
relief but few believe that will come
anytime soon greg milam sky news
poor little ma'am um health secretary
sergey javid is here and before we start
proper mr javid i just want to remind
our viewers of these images that we saw
towards the end of last week
when a hospital was hit it was a
maternity hospital this is what happened
um this was a lady that was being
stretchered out of that maternity
hospital i'm sure you'll remember the
images um
we believe uh we were just hearing
actually that
she had a cesarean section and the baby
has died and we're now also being told
that mum
has died as well
remember that the russian authorities
said that it was fake news is that a war
crime
yes i think it is um it's it's an
appalling atrocity it's a war crime
because under international law
you cannot attack
health facilities hospitals
and in fact
the recent most recent information i
have from the world health organization
is they now have documented evidence of
at least 31 such attacks of health
facilities hospitals including shelling
a couple of days ago of a cancer
hospital
as well so these are war crimes today
the justice secretary will be in the
hague he'll be meeting there with the
chief prosecutor and others to offer
britain's help in helping to gather the
evidence but also with a future
prosecution of president putin and his
team
and hospitals right across the country
that have been hit
they're right across the country yes
these are appalling atrocities and when
the british embassy the russian embassy
in britain says that it's fake news how
should we deal with that i know that
that tweet has subsequently been taken
down by twitter but nevertheless that's
the propaganda that there i mean the
only fake news is everything we hear uh
from russia i mean russia is we saw this
in this country with the salisbury
attacks and it's continued ever since
and we can see for ourselves what's
actually happening we've seen from you
know brave sky reporters we heard just
yesterday an american journalist uh was
killed uh by the russians so yeah
targeted
targeted killed and
it's an opportunity for me actually to
say to thanks to all the journalists
that are out there risking their lives
bringing us the real facts and the real
news of what's actually happening on the
ground okay um
15-minute drive away from the nato
border if you will aka poland
there was an attack yesterday 35 people
died and
it's edging ever closer to a challenging
nato
what happens if there is a missile just
the other side into the nato border
look we've been very clear even before
the war started
that
if if there was a an attack on any nato
country even if a just a single
toe cap of a russian soldier steps into
nato territory
then it will be war with nato and nato
would respond
and and that hasn't changed throughout
this conflict and there would be a
significant response from nato if there
was any kind of attack from russia and
we've been very very clear from that the
polish president wants to go further
than that a polish president is saying
if there is chemical attacks
in ukraine then it's a war that nato
should get involved with what's
britain's position on that that we've
been
clear about any kind of attack on nato
would be obviously unacceptable in
ukraine but it's a it's a chemical
attack
i'm not i'm not going to get into a
hypothetical situation about what may or
may not happen but we've been cleared i
mean and also okay to be perfectly frank
it's never helpful for us to set out in
advance what we may or we or may not do
in such a situation we wouldn't want to
tell the enemy what what the response
might be it just wouldn't make any sense
but
our message has been very clear from the
start is that any kind of attack
anything uh that touches nato territory
or impacts nato in in in in any
significant way then we would respond
but we don't set that out that kind of
response in advance and this attack um
on the base i believe that british
military personnel have been uh housed
there previously were there any there
when this attack happened on the board i
don't know the answer to that question
okay are we still sending what sort of
armed shipments are we sending
uh we have i mean so far we have
supplied the i think probably more than
any other country uh ukraine with uh
weapons i think there's something like 3
615 anti-tank weapons the so-called sort
of end-law anti-tank weapons and they've
they've helped ukraine significantly uh
so far and the defense secretary has
also said that we are considering uh
sending some other weapons including the
the star streak weapon which is a
anti-aircraft missile system and also
the javelin anti-an anti-tank missile
system okay talk to me about these
little ones that have got cancer and
have arrived in the uk what's the plan
well yeah so yesterday we received 21
very ill ukrainian children with cancer
they these are all children innocent
children of course they've been forced
to leave their home
because of the russian invasion and they
were all receiving treatment in in
ukraine they'll now be cared for by our
incredible nhs staff all here in the uk
and i'm also just very grateful to
all our partners that have helped to
make this happen the polish government
in particular and of course uh the nhs
to get these children out over the
weekend uh with their families and
they're all in different parts of the uk
there's six nhs hospitals that will
eventually receive them and give them
the treatment that they need and how
long are they allowed to stay
um as long as necessary really and so
the in the first instance just to get
them out very quickly they were all
given six-month visas but that's we're
going to extend that to at least three
years uh but it'll be up to them there
and whilst they're here is the children
uh with their mothers in one or two
cases with carers uh some siblings uh i
think it's 49 people in total and i just
think it's it's it's great that we can
help in this way and we said right from
the start we will stand with the people
of ukraine and and help in any way that
we can and they can stay for up to three
years
at least yeah and and beyond that it
will be up to them to to decide you know
what they wish to do but in you in the
in at least for three years uh they'll
be here and uh the children in
particular get all the medical treatment
that they need okay um what about other
finally finally we're pulling our finger
out and families can come to the uk but
they have to be
families in the uk who want to offer a
home have to have the name of a
ukrainian family how's that going to
work well it will work with the
charities that we are working closely
with so there are a number of charities
especially on the ground in poland and
in moldova and met they're already
receiving these charities with the help
of those respective governments a number
of people
there are people that have already or
will certainly continue to express an
interest in coming to the uk and through
those charities through the website
that's going live later this week they
will be connected and and that is how a
host will be able to say your i will
take a family of
this size your maybe a mother with two
or three children and i've got enough
space uh for them and they will be
connected and put together and so cap on
the number of people that can go no
there's no there's no cap and uh and
there shouldn't be because you know we
don't know sadly where where this uh war
is going to end we've seen that there's
already millions of of refugees there
will be uh many more uh but it's a it's
an open offer
for any british family to to extend its
hand and offer shelter and support do
you acknowledge that it's taken us too
long to get to where we are
no i i think it's it's been a difficult
process in in in responding to this in
in you we start we're actually one of
the first countries to offer
humanitarian support over 400 million
pounds of support so far i think more
bilaterally than any other country
we've offered we've talked about the
weapons and the military support
for my part in my department as well as
what we've just talked about about
helping these children we've already
sent seven flights of vital medicines
medical equipment medical supplies i
think i've got another one uh leaving
today we've done more in terms of
medical supplies than any country so i
think collectively we are doing a huge
amount as a country to help but it's
right that we do britain's are you know
that they will open their doors to
people if they possibly can and there
will be lots of barriers put in their
way up until now and thankfully it's
coming into place now all i'm saying is
do you acknowledge that potentially that
should have happened earlier look i i i
we all i think everyone would have want
to see the
help to ukrainian refugees as much as we
can as quickly as we can but it's also
worth saying as a country we do have a
very proud record of uh offering
sanctuary to people fleeing conflict and
war uh with the thousands of syrians and
afghans that have been resettled uh with
the support of over a hundred thousand
uh hong kong nationals that have applied
under the scheme that the prime minister
set out last year and and then again
with ukraine we will absolutely play our
part and and make sure we are
giving refuge to those that need it
what's happening it's happening now um
the prime we also know that the prime
minister is heading to saudi arabia over
the next day or so to talk about oil
it's a big challenge given
the sanctions against russia
saudi arabia executed 81 people over the
weekend
are we turning a blind eye to the
world's evils in order to get enough oil
to keep the lights on but we we have a
long-standing relationship with saudi
arabia and i can certainly tell you in
the time that i've been in government
under three prime ministers we've always
had a very candid and frank relationship
with saudi arabia where
wherever there are human rights issues
we've raised them with them and we can
do that because we have this
relationship but we also have an
economic relationship
with saudi arabia we're not dependent uh
directly as a country on their oil but
your energy prices and access to to
energy is a hugely important issue so
i'm pleased that we can have this
relationship with saudi arabia where we
can talk about the human rights issues
as well as are longer terms
to do business with a country that chops
people's heads off
well look we as i said we've got a
candid frank relationship with them it's
it's a very important country uh for us
and i think it is right the the prime
minister is leading this effort to
engage saudi arabia even more so in in
the events that we're seeing unfolding
now talk to me about um lebrodev um if
you would please lord lebverdev um you
tweeted in august 2020 that lebroded is
a first generation immigrant britain can
be very proud of do you still think that
um
well i
yes well i i think here we can be proud
of people that have settled in the uk
and helped build british businesses and
given in support for many charities and
good causes
i've got no reason to to to doubt
anything that i've said there but
obviously you're asking me this because
of the recent
reporting around lebadev uh receiving a
a peerage yeah and anyone who receives a
peerage in in the uk they all have to be
vetted by the house of lords nominations
commission but if this is and in this
case it's no different yeah but if the
security service you say is the security
risk the prime minister keeps pushing
and pushing and pushing and saying no i
want him to be a lord surely if our
security services who are the best in
the world say
i don't think so he may well be a
security risk surely we should take
notice of that well first of all i agree
that our security services are the best
in the world i've had the privilege to
work with them uh for many years
and and and it is right third uh for the
house of lords nomination commission if
they need to seek information from any
other part of the
the uk the authorities then they should
do so they should then
no but then they should take that into
account
and and
the domination commission should take
that into account and then complete this
vetting process and that's exactly
what's happened here and you're
comfortable with him keeping his
lordship yes i am okay final we're
almost out of time i just want to ask
you about delta cron and stealth omicron
where are we with all of that
well the we keep the situation very
carefully under review there's no other
variant of concern out there that that
is an issue at this point in time we
have seen some rises in infections of
the last week but given the increase in
social mixing this was to be expected so
the situation at the moment is stable
no there's no particular concern at this
point in time okay thank you for joining
us on the program i appreciate it thank
you let's find out what the papers are
doing this morning the story about the
mum and baby who have both died as a
result of that bombing at the mario paul
hospital has come too late for the front
pages the ft reporting that russia's
most deadly strike to date on a military
base near the polish border was meant as
a warning to nato not to supply weapons
to ukraine
the mirror says it's clear mr putin now
has the west in his sights they also
feature the pope's plea to president
putin in the name of god stop this
massacre
the times also reports russia has turned
to china for help with its military
campaign
refugees need you is the headline for
the metro as volunteers are urged to
take ukrainian refugees into their homes
and as russian forces continue their
advance on ukraine's capital at least
one person has been killed and three
wounded in shelling in and around kiev
overnight our special correspondent alex
crawford is in kiev for us right now hi
alex what's happened
morning okay morning everyone look at
this site the building's still smoking
at about 5 a.m this morning this huge
residential block was hit by a round of
artillery shells we're in the north of
the the city that's only seven miles
from the city center they're still
trying to retrieve their belongings
we believe all the people have been
taken out we're not sure about the
injuries or the deaths but this is quite
clearly a residential very much a
residential area right in the heart
of a whole group of housing right next
to a school that's the playground and
the school next door to it so this is
absolutely nowhere near anything that
would constitute a military target the
fire engines are about five or six fire
engines who've been trying to get people
out we've spoken to some of the the
residents inside who one of whom said he
had to carry his 84 year old mother out
who had been cut from
the you can see what it's done to the
building imagine if you're inside that
still sleeping as most people would have
been at five o'clock this morning
we've seen a number of the the residents
who once lived inside this block going
inside with um
fire
people trying to gather up whatever they
can the few possessions that might still
be intact and looking inside these
windows you can see a glimpse of
you know
ordinary people's lives who were just
sleeping there waking up to another
morning we know that this is the prize
for the russians we know that
the russian military sees capturing the
capital as key
to their military plans because the
president
has stayed here the government is here
and we've seen over the past 48 24 48
hours that uh
there's someone else coming out there
just picking out picking up their um
their belongings and and coming out a
lot of these people still very much in
shock but still showing the resilience
uh that we've seen throughout this cave
there you go someone else coming up and
this these are these scenes have been
unfolding for the past few hours and um
i mean pretty heart-wrenching or you
know they're just grabbing whatever they
can in some cases food in some cases
bits of belongings sometimes just
clothes being helped by soldiers and
civil defense and fire people
i was going on to say that we know that
in in monitor poll we saw the
capturing of the the mayor
which president zolensky sees as um
excuse me mum do you speak english no a
lot of these people are still very much
in in shock and
um not wanting to talk we've seen a
number of them coming out crying
um but the man that we spoke to who was
happy to talk to us was extremely
defiant and saying that
again urging um the international
community particularly the west to help
them more with with weapons to help them
with
closing the skies which they see
is
key to turning
this whole wall
and alex i'm sure you're aware story
that has developed within the last 20
minutes or so about the image that we
showed to our viewers many of them will
remember from the mariopol maternity
hospital this lady being carried out on
a stretcher after that bombing of the
hospital we hear that the baby
i can't believe this story the baby has
died
during the cesarean section and mum has
now also died as well
the russians saying it's fake news
that is absolutely tragic news we know
that um
very sadly the
russian military appears to be targeting
um places like hospitals and schools the
hospital if you remember that we
reported from a couple of days ago right
in the uh north east of of kiev um i
spoke to the doctor overnight there you
saw a number of soldiers coming in there
who who had been hit they have withdrawn
from that hospital now and come further
into the center of the capital because
the hospital
also came under attack and they had to
withdraw and shut down that facility so
i think there's no doubt having spoken
to the kiev chief of police that they
are mounting a dossier which they intend
to put forward to the international
criminal court and the hague
for them to investigate potential war
crimes but many of the ukrainians we're
speaking to feel very strongly that
there are crimes against humanity and
war crimes being committed on a daily
base here and certainly those inside the
capital are feeling much more
um
nervous but incredibly defiant every day
every
true throughout the day they're not
wasting any time by building up
barricades and and trying to reinforce
um the capital but
the the russian military and the the
advance of the russian military is is
edging ever closer to the center
okay alex just before i let you go give
me the geography of of where you are
again for viewers obviously tuning our
way all the time where are you and
what's happened sure
sure we're in the north of the city
we're only seven miles from the center
it's a big sprawling city and if you
take this the center to be um for
instance where the st sofia cathedral is
say we're seven miles north of that so
really a hop skip and a jump we're we're
in the city
the city area if you like kiev also has
a wider region like greater london has
we're inside that wider region so we're
seven miles from the center due due
north it's a district called obalon
we're really right in this is
residential area this is a huge
residential block it's right next to a
school and playing fields there's no way
anyone could have mistook this for a
military target
alex thanks very much indeed for the
uptick thank you
and the scene in kiev this morning where
reports are reaching us of at least one
dead three wounded after that russian
explosive hit a residential building
in the capital let's take you through
the other main developments for you uh
in just a moment before that though
let's bring in nick martin should we
he's standing by in odessa for us this
morning hi
nick the situation where you are this
morning
good morning kay where we are on the
main road between odessa and mikhail two
key
port cities on the south coast of
ukraine mikhail
for the last few days now has been under
bombardment rocket attacks shells it's
had a it's had a tough few days and that
is the road that we're on now we've just
stopped to talk to you you can see these
guys behind me these guys are just
members of the village just behind me
and they put up sort of makeshift
checkpoints along this main road to
protect their village and you see this
all the way up this road as you go
through checkpoints armed by the
military but also people taking their
the defense of their own communities
into their own hands these guys have got
themselves some weapons they've put some
tyres some
lumps of concrete that they've been able
to get and this road leads to their
village and their community and
they say they're determined to protect
themselves as the russian military come
through here um odessa behind us has
been preparing itself for whatever might
come the uk's defense
department said that there is evidence
to suggest that the russian navy are
carrying out a sort of distant
uh observation of this coast now uh
which would suggest that they are
planning some kind of assault on odessa
similar to the one we've seen in mikalia
if we're not quite sure what we'll see
when we go up this road this morning but
we know from reports that it has been
heavily shelled and thousands of people
are now trying to leave that port city
of in the last hour look here uh peace
talks have begun once again between
ukraine and russia they're not in person
they're via video call and everybody
hopes that there can be some
common ground found that might lead to
some kind of slowdown of this conflict
um but we're not when we go further up
this road and we end up near michaela
we'll be able to see a bit more for
ourselves
the scale of the damage there just you
were just talking with alex crawford
there about that dreadful news that that
came from mario paul that maternity
hospital we do have some more
information on that
that that image which circulated around
the world of that pregnant woman being
stretched away from the rubble of that
maternity hospital after it was struck
by russian forces was really a very
powerful image and we know that that
lady was taken to a hospital and
surgeons tried very hard to save her
they were resuscitating her for about 30
minutes and then they said they told the
associated press that she died and uh
they tried a cesarean section and the
baby died as well
that is tragic news and the russians
have always said that that there were no
women and children at this maternity
hospital that it was actually a base for
some militia defensive militia and uh
this news now proof uh that that it was
the the women and children were there
and that there were fatalities out of
that so here
people defending their own communities
and as we go further up the road we
should see more for ourselves the damage
caused to another key city macaulay just
just to the east of here kay okay thank
you thanks a lot
i can't even begin to imagine can you
that you know the safest place in a war
zone is supposed to be
a hospital and a mum at her most
vulnerable heavily heavily pregnant
and
a bomb hits the hospital
and she's stretched away by the military
personnel taken to another hospital as
nick was saying
they've done everything they can to save
her but we're hearing that both mum and
baby have died as a result i was going
to say it was cesarean section but
that's not why they died they died
because their hospital was bombed by
russian forces
set that sink in this morning this
monday morning
we're hearing that um
china's foreign ministry um has uh
commented on u.s officials saying russia
has asked china for military equipment
after its invasion in ukraine they said
that that is disinformation from the u.s
so china is saying that they have not
been asked
for military equipment by russia to help
with the invasion
and incursion of
ukraine and they're describing that as
disinformation as far as the u.s is
concerned a short while ago the health
secretary studied javid told me what
would happen if a russian missile hit
nato territory
look we've been very clear even before
the war started
that
if if there was a an attack on any nato
country even if a just a single
toe cap of a russian soldier steps into
nato territory
then it will be war with nato and nato
would respond and and that hasn't
changed throughout this conflict and
there would be a significant response
from nato if there was any kind of
attack from russia and we've been very
very clear from that
tomorrow's here wide-ranging interview
with him actually i thought it was very
interesting quite a lot of what the hell
secretary had to say this morning yes
absolutely but i think the key message
was when we see that the war in ukraine
is now on nato's doorstep the russians
bombing 15 miles from the polish border
people in that region of ukraine were
not expecting that some of them had even
taken in refugees from other parts of
ukraine which is a massive country
they'd come a very long way to be in the
relative safety of the west of ukraine
when that happens then there are stark
questions for the uk government and the
rest of the west we know that if a nato
country and that is most of the
countries bordering ukraine poland
slovakia hungary not moldova that's not
a member of nato but if any member of
nato is a victim of an armed attack all
other members of nato come in and defend
them under article 5. so if
as sajid javid puts it one russian toe
cap goes over the border even
accidentally then that means russia is
at war with the nato alliance and there
are serious considerations for what that
means whether it's troops whether it's
a full-scale you know war with with
countries in europe and the west now he
didn't go into exactly what that
response would be
but that is that is the level we are at
now yeah he also said of course i'm not
going to discuss with you here on
television what our response might be
but he did talk about war crimes we told
him about the lady that sadly has died
with her unborn child and he said that
attack along with attacks on 31 other
hospitals are war crimes yes revealed
that 30 yes 30 other hospitals had been
attacked by the russians and that um the
justice secretary has has been giving
evidence to um to the hague where
they're looking into to russian war
crimes that awful news coming from the
associated press the only journalists
who are currently in the besieged city
of mariopol where
we read over the weekend that over 2000
people including many children have died
in that city alone but that image of the
woman on the stretcher you know going to
hospital to give birth to her baby
just went so far around the world and
just really really tragic news yeah and
um just also as far as children coming
with cancer coming into the uk we a
flight came in yesterday they're here
with their families and interesting that
the health security's saying they could
stay as long as they want yes glimmer of
good news for some of those children
with cancer who'd had to have their
children have had their treatment halted
by the war 20 of them arrived in the uk
last night we read a bit over the
weekend about their journey from poland
they spent hours and days travelling to
get here they will now be treated he
suggested in six nhs hospital trusts we
don't know the full details of it yet
and
what under the scheme that has been
announced by the government for people
joining a relative in the uk they will
get a six-month visa initially and then
be able to stay for up to three years so
those children even though they don't
have a uk connection are being given
that status and of course we expect to
hear more details today about the rest
of the ukrainian refugees coming here
and how british families will be able to
put them up in their homes yeah i did
ask him whether um
he should have done that this before now
and he said we're doing it now we're
doing it now yeah you can sense the
tension in government there there has
been internal criticism in cabinet of
pretty patel and the home office's
response some defend her saying look
she's being told by the security
services that you have to vet people but
others are saying you have to weigh up
what might be a very small risk of
russian infiltrators versus the enormous
humanitarian crisis unfolding in front
of us i think it's interesting and
perhaps uh not a coincidence that
michael gove is fronting up this new
scheme not the home secretary yeah
reading to that what you will um we'll
tomorrow's tech at nine o'clock lots to
talk about thank you tomorrow meantime
the former chief of the defence staff
general lord richard dunn is with us now
hello my lord thank you for joining us
on the program this morning uh first of
all if i may your thoughts
on the mum and baby that have both sadly
died um as a direct result really of the
bombing by russians on one of 31
hospitals in ukraine
okay good morning um the whole the story
of what's been going on in ukraine for
nearly nearly three weeks is quite
appalling but this latest episode um
one struggles with one's thesaurus one
struggles to find words that can condemn
this kind of action sufficiently it is
absolutely tragic that a mother and
child are killed in this way but i'm
afraid it's an inevitable consequence of
the completely
outrageous tactics that the russians are
using
they have realized that they haven't got
sufficient manpower to attack
cities like kiev or even mariopol so
they've surrounded them and they're
shunning them and this is a disgraceful
way of conducting war
but from vladimir putin's point of view
he's getting short of options and this
is the tactic that he has resorted to
and therefore the inevitable consequence
is this absolutely appalling tragedy of
this mother and child dying is quite
disgraceful it defies
it it defies human life for the 21st
century
also
targeting
a military barracks if you will
peacekeepers there as well um 10 minutes
from the nato border
that is perilously close to looking for
war
with all nato countries
well
that's right but i think we've got to
keep this one in perspective
any
of the territory of ukraine from the
russians point of view is a legitimate
target
insofar as they have
launched an and are waging war against
ukraine and therefore their actions have
shown that they are not differentiating
between
the east of the country or indeed now
the west of the country
so yes of course it is very close 10
miles a very short drive from poland and
therefore from nato territory but
critically this was on ukrainian
territory it was a ukrainian military
base and therefore in russian eyes
um where
they prepared to justify anything um
that was a legitimate target but again
um it's close to a border crossing point
it's close to where people are fleeing
the country so again it's another
example of
the total irresponsibility and the total
savagery which vladimir putin and his
acolytes and his troops are conducting
against against ukraine and you know
once again one says ukraine has an
absolute right for the people there to
live the life that they chose they
choose to live uh they've chosen
democracy they've chosen to uphold the
rule of law so we are quite right in
supporting them and applauding them and
condemning in the roundest possible
fashion everything that vladimir putin
and the russians are doing
what are we how are we supposed to deal
with president putin when we're told
that the russian delegation is
continuing with peace talks and uh tell
us that there are a couple of days left
with those peace talks is that while
they've paused to regroup and
potentially get weapons from other
countries or is that because president
putin wants peace
well this is all part of the information
war that is going on and the information
war of course is going on on several
fronts um one within ukraine itself um
backing up
the rocket attacks the missiles the
artillery strikes to wear down the
population uh in ukraine on another
front uh it's disinformation to the
people back at home in in russia to try
and um
tell them through the fake news that's
coming out from the kremlin that the war
is legitimate it's it's it's fair it's
reasonable uh and this is all about
russia and the russian way of life and
then of course the third audience is all
of us in the west and the rest of the
world
and
well we are doing our best or you are
the media are doing their best to report
this whole war as objectively and
as factually and as clearly as possible
but uh it is very difficult to
distinguish truth from untruth truth
from from fake news but it's really
important that word does get out
properly around the world just about the
appalling nature of what the russians
are doing the appalling leadership that
putin is showing and the
barbaric way that they their military
tactics have now morphed away from
direct contact because the fact that
they haven't got enough troops to uh
indiscriminate shelling to wear down the
ukrainian population in the hope that
eventually president valencia will have
to say well we can't put up with this
anymore we'll have to come to the table
and start talking it's a barbaric way of
conducting warfare
murdering journalists deliberately
targeting journalists who are trying to
do their jobs in ukraine to bring news
to the rest of the world is just utterly
barbaric and to that end we are as you
know our stuart ramsey was also shot in
similar circumstances with his the rest
of his team targeted in a vehicle and we
are hoping that we will be able to speak
to um stuart um later on in the week
once he has fully recovered from his
injuries meantime
children and mums are coming out of the
country finally we know that there was a
flight with children um suffering from
cancer who've been brought to the uk in
the last 24 hours they've been told they
can stay the health secretary telling us
just now they can stay as long as they
want to last time we spoke my lord
you're very critical of the government
you didn't think that they were doing
enough to help refugees what do you
think now
well it's taken time but the government
has now woken up to the fact that the uk
has major responsibilities as all
civilized western countries have to play
our part in making it possible for
refugees to come to this country
and i think michael gove's scheme of
inviting private citizens to sign up to
to take a ukrainian family to their home
with some remuneration to defray the
cost of that i think is a sensible one i
think the other issue which i find
puzzling still is the whole issue of
well people have got to be vetted um
we're not dealing with
people coming out of
syria
or iraq
where there are concerns about
terrorism and islamist terrorism or
whatever these are european people whose
country is under threat uh ukrainians
and i think frankly we need to be
prepared to take a risk uh and let
people come in and if necessary vet them
once they've got here
the
really important thing here is that we
are
open open open armed we're warm-hearted
and that this country uh plays its part
to the maximum to be possible and okay
you'll remember last week you and i were
talking about the hundred thousand
children that uh are in
orphanages in in ukraine well it's
encouraging the support that british
people have shown to charities like open
homes for children and also street child
both charities are working really hard
to help those children who otherwise
haven't got families to look after them
so at long last the british government
has woken up and unsurprisingly the
great british public has very much
stepped up to the plate open homes for
children's a website went manic last
week after you and i talked about this
and street child also has gained a lot
of donations because they're doing
really good practical work with their
volunteers in the area helping these
children uh helping these mothers as
well and it just shows that
when these awful situations pertain the
british people are really good at
stepping up to the mark so you know i
would say on behalf of both those
charities open homes for children and
street child thank you for what you're
doing it is really making a difference
you are very welcome um to take time on
our program whenever you'd like to my
lord thank you very much indeed for
joining us
just want to tell you that we're just
hearing uh that ukraine will try to
evacuate trapped civilians again today
through 10 humanitarian corridors um
including from the times near the uh
capital kiev and also the eastern region
of lehance hearing from the deputy prime
minister
he's saying we will once again try to
unblock the movement of
the humanitarian convoy carrying food
and medicine to the port city of
mariopol from berniansk in southeastern
ukraine that of course i should say she
it is a female isn't it the um
the deputy prime minister uh of
the ukrainian capital so we will get
more information on that and update you
further as soon as we can
but away from ukraine the war uh
in fact we'll return to that in just a
moment with the very latest information
but before that the latest covet data
shows a new highly contagious strain
dubbed stealth omicron now dominant in
england that's as infections rise again
with us now is professor paul moss from
the university of birmingham's institute
of immunology and immunotherapy hello to
professor thanks for joining us i did
raise this with the health secretary a
few moments ago he said he wasn't unduly
concerned
i think that's a fair assessment as you
say this ba2 variant is perhaps 40
percent more infectious um it's over 50
percent of cases now in this country and
it's becoming dominant around the world
but there doesn't seem to be any change
in the epidemiology with this virus
it seems that protection infection with
omicron gives you some protection
against this strain so i think that's a
reasonable assumption saying no great
concern at the moment
but why then are hospital admissions
rising i think 15 in a week
yeah it's interesting isn't it we knew
when the changes were made the
relaxation we'd either see a slowing of
the decline or an increase and you're
right we've seen an increase 50 percent
increase in cases in the last week and
some increase in hospitalizations as you
say although some of those could be
incidental i think the death rates are
remaining moderately stable actually so
that's encouraging so i think you know
we've got the boosters coming through
for the older people in april i think at
the moment things are steady as we go to
no change at this stage i think that's
reasonable
i had my third bout of um
uh kovy just last week um and i have to
say two days and i was clear again are
we have we turned a corner on this
disease
this infection
it seems at the moment in many countries
certainly here with our great immune
protection and vaccination we've got
things under good control haven't we but
we've seen in places such as hong kong
quite serious problems but you're right
i mean there's a
some work last week showing that the
fatality right now of courvid in in this
country is down to the level of about
influenza so it's starting to be
comparable with that so we are learning
to live with this now
and delta cron and stealth omicron is
there a difference between them um if
you're lying in bed watching the telly
this morning with a runny nose or not
yeah there is a difference delta cron is
something very different it's a bit more
of a scientific curiosity
um okay what's really happened there is
in the when delta and omicron were
circulating in the population somebody
or a few people got the same the two
viruses at the same time and in a single
cell uh delta and omicron came together
and exchanged material it's called a
recombination there's only been a few of
those
variants discovered and they've been
around for two months but they haven't
taken off so we're hoping that they're
no more than a scientific curiosity
okay um well as i said um i
got better much quicker this time
hopefully a lot of our viewers who may
well have contracted uh covert as well
that will be some hope for them
professor it's good to talk to you thank
you very much thank you
thanks a lot
let's go back to ukraine with a struggle
to defend itself against russian
aggression has truly become a national
effort as well as civilians veterans are
taking up arms to defend their country
there's been another strike just a few
miles from the capital ukraine oh kiev
this morning one person has died three
people have been injured in this
apartment block
let's uh bring in should we evona
kostiano who co-founded veteran hub in
kiev which supports the well-being of
ukrainian veterans and their families
good morning to you ivana and you see
pictures like this it must make those
that you are trying to support very
anxious
good morning yes it's true among the
veteran population what is happening now
to the civilians is devastating to them
and they feel very angry and
they're trying to do their best to
defend the civilian population at the
moment in ukraine
what's the role of the charity what do
you hope to achieve
before the war we were investing in the
well-being of veterans and we were
helping them reintegrate the civilian
life we had about 460 000 veterans in
ukraine before uh february 24th now of
course the number will be rising uh as
soon as we have first people coming back
from the battlefields
but now we are i'm capable of doing our
work in full scape because the regions
where we were working are either under
heavy shelling like key where you see
the
photo and video on your screens at the
moment and nipro and even in vindica
where we are situated which is
relatively west we still have some
shellings happening and constant
syringes that are preventing people from
doing their work but also our clients
the veterans are mostly joining service
and they're at the moment un
uh able to
interact with us and so we've shifted to
working with their families and their
loved ones to support them through this
devastating period and to help them
overcome all the threats and all the
worry that they have now in their lives
are two quick thoughts before i let you
go vona um how can people help what can
we do to help you
spread the word spread the word about
the real situation here in ukraine about
videos like the ones you're seeing
because this is really happening and
this is what we're all living through
and we will have to spend a lot of years
after this is over in overcoming the
consequences both infrastructurally but
first of all in the lives of people and
in the way they um
they build their lives forward
and we are almost out of time but i did
just want to get your uh reaction of
owner to the news that the mum-to-be
that we saw stretched away from the
mario paul hospital has lost her life um
as has her baby both perished um
your reaction to that news
that is horrible news and the one that
probably um
made us all most
horrified in the last
weeks or so
but she joined almost 2 000 civilians
who have died in the last week in
mariupol and they continue dying every
day and there is no way to get them help
and that is just
unfair to those people living in marine
pool
yeah
do keep safe we can see just how close
the shelling
is to the capital now and as you said
lives perishing all the time but thank
you very much indeed for taking the time
to join us and for the great work that
you do with those that come back from
battle thank you
thank you
so let's have a quick look at a couple
of pictures should we uh that were
illustrated in the uh papers this
morning the guardian has the shot of a
metro station in kharkiv where up to a
thousand people are staying seeking
refuge from russian attacks
and uh the telegraph has this image of
the destruction left behind by the
conflict one more for you the daily mail
has this dramatic shot of the
international peacekeeping and security
center in west ukraine on fire after a
missile attack